burnout isn't real I just got off the
phone with an eight figure plus CEO that
was contemplating shutting down his
entire business because he felt burnt
out I'm going to release my side of the
conversation with him so that I can show
you the unlocks that we went through
never done this before it's an
incredibly powerful call you can unlock
the unlimited motivation that I think he
was able to tap into by the end of it
you do not have mental illness you are
not mentally unhealthy you do not have
anything wrong with you
if anything you have a lot of stuff
right with you I think that you were
really hard on yourself you're not only
doing great you're doing extraordinary
like you're doing very well and so
whatever voices you have in your life
internal or external that are telling
you otherwise
you need to stop listening to them I
tweeted this morning and I was thinking
about you do not listen to people whose
dreams for your life are smaller than
yours like parents friends
only person who can know who knows how
big you dream is you and if someone does
have bigger dreams for you than you do
then you should absolutely listen to
them you know what I mean but if you
don't then their advice is not valid
that you don't share a common future and
most advice should come from a shared
common goal but most people give advice
that serves them through your behavior
which is another way it's called
manipulation like the difference between
help and manipulation is intention all
we do when we communicate with anyone in
general is to manipulate their behavior
or change their behavior your goal is to
change your behavior from this call I
hope that this decreases your stress
level because it reframes how you act in
the company and in so doing
allows you to go further because right
now what feels unsustainable to you is
unsustainable because you've defined it
as unsustainable what happens is people
start defining normal as good and that
is the problem
normal is normal normal is average
and so we have to be different than
average or different than normal or
extraordinary in order to achieve an
extraordinary outcome I want to say Andy
Grove who said only the paranoid survive
arguably one of the goat operators of
the century who basically turned Intel
around saying that only the paranoid
survived and you hear like Steve Jobs
like he was obsessive and he was he was
difficult to deal with and so if we try
and use standard is this guy normal the
obvious answer is no and I hope not and
so a lot of these character traits that
I feel like I've heard you say about
yourself that are set in a negative
light
said differently it's just they are not
the same as other people
well we can't hope to be have a
different outcome from other people and
then also hope to have the same
behaviors viewpoints beliefs and skill
sets right
so like you gotta let your lungs adjust
the altitude like you just went up like
three rungs of success you know I mean
from when you and I started talking
whatever you're almost I think not even
far it's been like six seven months and
the business is triple what's
interesting though is that you were in
pain then and I would say that you're in
equal pain now changing the
circumstances or our conditions is not
going to change how you feel we changed
your conditions we actually massively
improved them your feelings didn't
change which means that the feelings are
not valid
doesn't mean they don't exist
it just doesn't mean that we have to
listen to them managing stress is a
learned skill it doesn't come from
changing conditions anything external
does not influence how stressed you are
the Judgment you have about the
externals what influences how stressed
you
I don't like the term mindset you know I
mean I hate it overall but
in terms of like reframing and
perspective shifts I think those are
powerful to think through which is at
the end of your life you will probably
be equally satisfied and dissatisfied
there will be things that you will wish
you have you would have accomplished and
there will be things that you will be
proud that you had done
the same as right now and so I think
it's much more about
figuring out how to separate your
internal dialogue and feelings or at
least respond to your feelings from the
external you don't have to go through
the fire the fire gives you evidence
that you have the trait you can be
impatient person but never been tested
but the moment you've tested you have
evidence that you're a patient so all it
does is it gives us reinforcement that
what we thought about ourselves all
along was true
what is the practice of doing this it's
being able to separate and identify when
you feel stressed
step one I feel stressed I feel it and
whatever your your triggers are for me I
feel tight in my chest that's how I know
that I start feeling stressed so when I
feel that I think okay what is causing
this what is the trigger that I have
chosen to judge is good or bad what is
the label that I'm ascribing to a
situation if to peel back the liar and
say what is it and then usually if you
take it all the way down it means that
you think you're going to die
sales reload today which means sales are
going to be low forever which means I'm
going to have to fire everyone which
means everyone's going to hate me I'm
going to be isolated and alone and I'm
going to die right just because you
think it doesn't mean it's true thoughts
are not true not all thoughts are true
they're just thoughts famous feelings
they're just they're literally just
chemicals in your brain that are meant
to keep you alive
not to help you succeed
when you feel stressed stop and be like
ah I'm feeling emotion here
I wonder what is causing this what am I
labeling is bad do I need to change
anything about this external condition
probably not
so do I think that law of large numbers
is that if I have 365 days
and I did the exact same thing there's
going to be days that are in the bottom
10 and days that are in the top 10 with
the exact same conditions like in terms
of behaviors answer is yes
and so I just described this as like oh
this just might be one of those bottom
10 days
and bottom 10 days happen every 10 days
independent it's three a month it's
almost every other you know every week
ish and even of those 36 days you might
even be in a bottom 10 day of those
which is about a one percent day 3.6
days a year [ __ ] horrible days but
doesn't mean we need to change our
Behavior probably not because our
Behavior over a long trend line has
tripled this business
I feel for how much you beat yourself up
because I too beat myself up and I do
know what it's like to be miserable
and I prefer not being miserable if I
have approvals Victor Frankel's man
search for meeting the man's in a
[ __ ] Hall like in the Holocaust right
he's like happyish so if he can be happy
there then me making a [ __ ] out of money
being young and healthy and married in
the most developed country in the world
do I really have any reason when covet
hit the first three weeks a shitload of
gyms closed my judgment of that was that
they were people who wanted to have a
reason that was socially acceptable for
losing
they were just waiting
and then finally they had an out that
they could be like covet and everybody
like ah shucks
not to say that external conditions
don't affect things they do but
the wave of gyms that I saw that really
wanted to keep going but couldn't happen
at like month nine when the second
shutdown happened they ran out of cash
they literally couldn't keep the doors
open but the ones that happened in the
beginning had lost the will to fight
and so my goal for this call was to
renew your will to fight because if we
can separate your internal feelings from
the external conditions that are around
you you can be unbelievably successful
now if it is uncomfortable of course it
is it's expected to be that's why it's
growing pains because if they were doing
the same thing you were doing before
then you would already have adapted to
it which is why like I said you got to
let your lungs adjust to the air it's
thinner fewer people can stand it
there's more but it does normalize
just like when you look back at which
you were running a million dollar
business and you were stressed out of
your mind then you're equally stressed
out now but you would wish to have the
problems you had with a million dollar
business because you have adjusted your
lungs are stronger now the things that
you're doing are not even impossible
they've been well documented and done
for for decades by other companies so
it's purely between your ears
which is good news because it means all
we have to do is reframe reality when
you feel stress
you do not need to behave stressfully
because the plan
is solid
we just need our commitment to the plan
to be just as solid I think you just
have to be able to like create space if
you think about one of those like Yeti
mugs you know what I'm talking about you
can have something hot on the inside and
does it's not hard to hold it and it
stays hot for a while the difference is
that there's separation there's air
between the outside and the inside it
could be cold outside it'd be hot
outside it's not going to change the
temperature on the inside of the bottle
it's like you need to be more like a
Yeti right now if it gets colder your
inside gets colder if it gets hotter the
inside gets hotter but the more you can
stay constant independent of the
external conditions I feel stressed air
that's because I have labeled something
externally as hot
but is it I have an external stressor do
I need to feel stress space What If This
Were good what if this is normal what if
this is to be expected what if this is
just the bottom 10 day it's just
statistics of course I'm gonna have a
bottom 10 today one out of ten days is
about 10 percent and on the flip side
something internally is off space it
doesn't mean that I need to act that way
so it's bi-directional if you delay the
space between when you feel something
and when you behave I promise you the
behaviors that you will do after you had
some space will be more aligned with
your long-term goals
to have the expectation that building a
business that's going to set you up for
the rest of your life is going to be
easy is ridiculous the reason it is
difficult for people is because you have
to change how you view reality and you
have that power you're super
introspective you're very caring you
have all the character traits of an
excellent Studio the only thing that you
suffer from is insecurity and second
guessing less emotionally reactive more
confident being able to continue to do
without seeing the result of your doing
if you embody those traits this company
will grow beyond what I think you expect